Rick Neuheisel joins us now on
Continental Tire coaches corner the CBS
college football analyst former college
coach where do you want to start with
what happened on Saturday Rick the
drubbing in in Miami that that was a
shocking development there the turnover
chain is become the the envy of all that
was an unbelievable performance by that
Miami defense but Auburn with what they
did to Georgia so Miami at home
i s I'm not that surprised Auburn
against Georgia that surprised me a
little bit more believe it or not and it
looked like a physical mismatch yes and
and we we had come to believe that
Georgia was the physical equivalent
maybe even of Alabama
Kirby smart having recently toiled there
you know and yet our burn looked that
much more superior in the trenches yeah
that was a shocker to I guess I would
say having watched a burn over the
course of the year and despite you know
when the protection breaks down is when
they fall in harm's way which has
happened in both the trips to Death
Valley but to me it looked as if Georgia
was a little worn out I did the game the
week before or Georgia and South
Carolina which was a physical physical
game and and maybe it just it wore it
wore the Bulldog fronts down Alabama
escapes Mississippi State and he
surprised there well I think they
responded the way a championship team
does Jalen hurts I thought was was
really good late in the game but it begs
the question especially having looked at
Auburn's front can they hang in there
physically because they are down to not
some not much rubber on the road you'd
never count a guy like Nick Saban out
and certainly their five star guys or
five star guys but to play as many plays
you know one of those luxuries Alabama's
enjoyed over the years is their
defensive guys don't have to play that
many plays they have so many guys that
can roll in that's going to be more
difficult and
in a trench warfare we're gonna see in
dirt and hair in a couple weekends that
will be a something to keep your
handicap nice though the rest of the
season look in that crystal ball what do
you see well you know we were talking
about Georgia and Alabama could both get
into the playoff now that that focus
shifts to the ACC can Miami and Clemson
both get in with Miami playing the way
they are assuming that they don't
stumble they have Virginian pit left in
the regular season and then a matchup
with Clemson I think Miami might be the
number one team in the land when they
when they when they talk about this next
poll coming out I mean that was an
impressive win over an impressive team
they're the undefeated team they in
Alabama they look better than Alabama in
this particular weekend people are going
to be concerned about Alabama's depth as
we just talked about if you put Miami up
there at the 1 or 2 spot then you've got
Clemson me do they move to three and if
they play a spirited game in Charlotte I
I just think you're gonna be looking at
the possibility of maybe two ACC teams
and who would have thought that a few
weeks ago when Clemson went down to
Syracuse
he's Rick Neuheisel Cottonelle entire
Coach's Corner the CBS college football
analyst but if I look at some of these
other team let give me somebody outside
of the top 10 I I asked this to Kirk
Herbstreit last week he said Michigan
State and then that didn't last very
long so do you have a dark horse here
USC I think the Trojans are kind of
sneaking around the chicken Coker they
have found a way now we saw what happens
when you take one on the Virginia Tech
for instance was kind of that dark horse
that sexy dark horse a few weeks ago
they get one on the chin by Miami and
then they stumble again
Georgia Tech getting them this last week
USC took one on the chin in South Bend
and it was a game that everybody thought
Arizona State was going to was going to
get him they had him in the desert they
had him wounded and they went there and
played maybe their best football game
and have played terrific ly they
clinched the South they're going to get
a chance to finish off the Bruins this
then they go and get a week off before
the before the championship game if they
play well against whether it's
Washington State Stanford or Washington
if they whip them I wouldn't be
surprised for them to get a lot of favor
and maybe slide into that sore spot
you know the quarterbacking position as
well as anybody you were a quarterback
coach in the NFL and of course played
the position give me a pro assessment a
Baker Mayfield who joins us in the final
hour today
then you and I talked about this earlier
in there I don't know of a guy who has
more arm talent that we've seen in
college football for some time I really
don't and and maybe the guy that I
compare him to is maybe the last guy we
saw this way and any any sparks
comparison because of his size as well
that's drew Brees we have we talked to
Jim Chaney last week they one-time
through 86 passes is that Purdue with
Drew Brees as their quarterback he has
an innate ability to throw people open
regardless of where the receiver is
relative to the DB the ball goes in a
place where only the receiver can make a
play Drew Brees is made in Hall of Fame
career out of that and Mayfield seems to
have the same stuff he also has the
ability to extend plays may be superior
to Brees in that regard but I think the
guy's going to end up being a
first-round pick he just has it and the
Oklahoma Sooners are in the playoff
conversations strictly because of it how
many quarterbacks you think are taken in
the top ten this year well depending on
darn 'old you know darn 'old to me is
still probably a 50/50 but he's starting
to round back into form I would say
you've got Rosen you've got Darnell
we'll wait and see about the big kick
from Josh Allen from Wyoming and I would
say Mayfield I would say four if
everybody's have I'm gonna give you the
number one pick
you need a quarterback out of the group
you just told me who you taking if I
have to take the quarterback I think I'm
going Mayfield
I just I just like the kids swagger I
like his ability to make plays he's all
football all the time over roses worry
about yeah and I love Rosen I I love
Rosen but the question for me with Rosen
how important is football to Rosa yeah I
I don't know that it's it's everything
and form a field he's passed that test
and with in spades
well GM's are gonna ask that question
what but I mean you're asking that about
rosin why well you know he comes from a
family where money was never something
that concerned him he you know as as
missed games we don't know exactly for
what reasons he you know because he's to
have a Hall of Fame career essential to
him I just I just thought that's a
question I have never taken time to
really get to know Josh Rose and I've
met him on a couple occasions he's an
impressive guy he certainly has all the
attributes you're looking for at
quarterback so if you gave me the two
spot and somebody took my field and I
had Rosen I'd be excited about it but if
I have to pick a guy that I know is
dying to win and I I think I have to go
with Mayfield especially the way he
plays the game good stuff is always Rick
great to talk to you thanks for joining
us all right Dan take care Rick
Neuheisel
who usually brings his guitar when he
joins us in the man cave in New York
that's pretty hot take their the Baker
Mayfield is your top quarterback going
in who would have thought that three
weeks ago month ago I got the the fire
truck now just the lights are on no
siren today we had truck drivers who got
upset with us so we have the the fire
truck lights are on that's a hot take
there yeah pulling that's official if
you say you take Baker Mayfield over
Josh Rosen Sam Arnold that's scalding
hot Continental Tire coaches corner from
Sun to rain to snow and everything in
between Continental tires engineered
tire for what you do extraordinary
performance reliability putting
competence into driving for more info
and the location of a Deerling near you
visit Continental Tire calm continental
time for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]